So have you ever wondered who actually invented the Internet?
Some people have become Zilli days thanks to the Internet,
but all they did was invent clever ways of using the internet.
So the person who invented the Internet should be a gazillionaire equivalent to
see God,
shouldn't they?
Who should get the credit then?
Was it a British key?
Can a Swiss underground neighbor,
maybe clever Americans threatened with nuclear annihilation by the Russians?
Nice idea.
French scientist who decided to call that computer network the [inaudible] on
it.
Interesting.
Or was it thanks to a myriad of smart scientists working on something they knew
was useful but didn't realize would be so big?
Well,
let's try and get some facts straight.
There's the Internet,
the whole bunch of computer networks connected to each other,
and then there's the worldwide web,
a way of making it easier to share information using all those interconnected
computers.
The Internet,
as we know it today,
was at least 40 years in the making.
One popular but wrong story is that the Internet was developed by the u s so
they had a communication that work that would survive a nuclear war.
According to one of the founders of the first network,
the arpanet and the 1960s this first network experiment wasn't about
communication at all.
It was about optimizing process or usage or timesharing,
which basically meant that scientists could share computer power to.
That was because until the 1960s there was basically no network.
You had big machines called mainframes,
which Saturday Roman and processed computing tasks one at a time.
With time sharing these bare mosques could process several tasks at a time,
which meant that power could be used by several scientists at once and obviously
once you start connecting computers together,
you start to wonder about what you need to do to make communications between
them,
easier scientists around the world.
We're trying to solve this problem.
So let's look at some of the other key concepts that were developed elsewhere.
Starting with packet switching in Britain,
there was a commercial network developed by the national physical laboratory,
but which never really got off the ground because it didn't get funding,
but they did come up with the idea of packet switching,
a way of avoiding congestion in busy networks by cussing update on one end and
putting it back together at the other.
The French also played a role.
They were working on a scientific network called [inaudible],
but they didn't have a big budget,
so they decided to work on direct connections between computers as opposed to
working with gateway computers.
Now,
as an aside here,
this admittedly isn't very scientific,
but according to one theory,
a spit off of their research was the word and tack on Net,
but you don't have to believe it if you don't want to.
So now it's the early 1970s there's quite a lot of computer infrastructure,
but communication is awkward and patchy because different networks can't talk to
each other.
TCP Ip solves this problem.
The TCP Ip protocols form the basic communication language of the Internet,
which labels the packets of data and make sure that even though some pieces of
the same data take a different route,
they all arrive at their destination and can be reassembled.
Networks really began communicating with each other in 1975 so you could argue
that was the beginning of the Internet.
Email was also very important.
It was developed for Arpanet in 1972 most internet traffic in 1976 was email
because academics thought electronic posted notes were dead call with networks
that could talk to each other.
Communication was becoming easier,
but all this communication was just text based and it was pretty ugly to look
at.
In the 1980s of Bret called Timothy Berners Lee spent time with cern,
the European Organization for nuclear research where physicists are trying to
work out what the universe is made of.
He wanted to manage the scientist's information and make it possible for them to
shat and interconnect their work easily,
making progress.
More likely he did.
So by inventing an interface using http,
html,
and URLs that made internet browsers possible.
He called his browser the worldwide web,
so he didn't invent the Internet,
but he did invent the web.
The first ever website which he created was at cern in France in August,
1991 so once the initial infrastructure was in place,
the key technologies had been invented.
Internet message boards exploded in the 1980s the phone companies saw the
commercial potential of digital communication.
Web Browser spread like wildfire.
In the early 1990s and ordinary people discovered email then the internet
expanded rapidly and steadily and became workable for the masses from about 1995
hold on,
didn't us,
vice president Al Gore invented the Internet.
Ah,
no.
And if you read what he said exactly,
you'd know he never claimed to have done,
but many people credit him with energetically pushing legislation that
encouraged the spread of the Internet.
The Internet exists because we need to communicate,
and most of us like doing it.
That's why humans have become the dominant species on earth.
You could argue that the Internet is a natural evolutionary step and a
manifestation of that need.
It wasn't invented by anyone in particular,
but when the building blocks were put together by all those cool scientists from
all over the place,
the Internet became a communication tool,
a retail tool or research tool of propaganda,
tall,
a spying tool,
a shopping tool,
a dating tool,
an entertainment tool,
and a way of skiving off work.
Well,
making it look like you're,
or studying,
which is what you may be doing now.
Ultimately though your communicating,
especially if you leave a comment and that might make you a better human being.
Okay.